the parents were off and vacationing and
jet setting around the world like i wore
his robe
i smoked cigars at that point we got
really cocky and we're just going
through all their
hello and welcome to the roast of your
teenage self podcast i am your host your
roast coming queen a girl who smoked
weed one time in the woods and
immediately cheated on her boyfriend
elise morales
and with us today we have
such a funny comedian you know him from
the daily show conan kimmel the tonight
show showtime
nbc cbs all the networks he's the
co-founder
of the all things comedy network but
before all of that
he was a graduate of saint ignatius
college preparatory high school
it's all magical yeah
yes uh it all started at same ignatius
college prep
i actually went to so
[Music]
you know graduated from high school in
um and just we just had our 30th
anniversary
uh which was incredible i did i went i
this is the first one i had actually
gone to i
really enjoyed it a lot of people that
cold told me this is cracking me and my
friends have to keep doing what i'm
doing
hey it seems like it's going well hey
you need to uh i just want to say keep
doing what you're doing
okay so let's get into it is that that's
a perfect place for us to start
so you said they call you call it s-i
sanding mage s-i so there's in in san
francisco there's uh
just to walk you through in the city
proper there's
a west coast coast athletic league
considers
s.i saint ignatius sh and those are the
rivals
and as you have uh sacred
heart versus saint ignatius that was a
big rivalry both have gone co-ed
now um and then there's reardon which
was another all-boys school
and then you compete like tom brady went
to sarah barry bonds went to sarah which
was in san mateo and they competed in
our league and then there was saint
francis
bellarmine and midi all competing in
like the same conference
so there was those are all the catholic
sort of
high schools in the san francisco bay
area so did
did like each school have kind of like a
reputation
like were they like oh si like that's
the stoner school yeah they used to call
us the cherries
and it was um
it was yeah it was we were all the sort
of preppy
city kids that was the uh and my dad
went to my dad also went to the same
high school
so my dad graduated from there in 1956
and we shared in common we both had the
same math teacher
so yes so fresh freshman year i was his
last years
jb murphy who is this old and he taught
dum-dum math so me and my dad
not great math students uh to both have
the dumb-dumb math
teacher that was historically it was
like his first year teaching
and his last year teaching and so think
about that
my dad as a freshman in 1954
53 had my teacher that i had in 1986
that's wild and when you had the same
math teacher as your dad did he
would he be like you madrigals you never
learned to divide no i mean he was he
was sold
no so old at that point i don't know if
it registered um
would walk in just he was ancient uh
yeah he said he was he was so old
i it was like that uh cartoon caricature
of the turtle from you know there you
see the old
wise turtle like he looked exactly like
that and just like
walked in and spoke he sat down at the
desk
not much math was done i remember
sophomore year cheating and copying
problems
out of our um
uh workbook to have so i could have some
sort of example because i didn't know
how
trigonometry worked at all like there's
no way i could possibly do it
and i remember this mr quatrain because
i copied coincidentally that
he took the workbook
and put it on the test like so all the
workbook problems ended up being on test
so i had
every answer in front of me and i copied
it down i cheated
and he's like see you can do this and i
see yes i can't i can't do it because i
can't my brain doesn't work like that i
have no idea
how any of this works and it just
luckily you know eventually
found uh and i was wasn't until senior
year that i really got involved in the
school because
at 13 years old i went from my high
school where i was student body
president
you know a decent athlete and went to
the school
didn't make any sports teams at all try
tried out for every single one of them
tried out for the play i was the lead in
the grammar school play but didn't got
cut
we all uh play on this podcast oh yeah
we were
uh guys and dolls and i was uh sky
masterson oh my god
yeah and sang i split it with another
guy
so we both played the same role with
different nights
classic and then i was also um
an understudy to was nathan detroit was
the
other lead in that the other male lead
played by frank sinatra i think
and so yeah i i had to understand him so
i knew
every single part and um
so i went to high school and all that
went away i was the
you know i was the hot shot in this high
school with a ton of friends all my
friends made the football team so they
made
new friends and it sort of left
me stranded
without anybody i remember taking the
bus home and being super sad because i
didn't have any activities
and i have i really wanted to
participate in something i wrote crew
for a little bit wow um i did i did that
for two years
and sort of gave up on that because i
wasn't good at it
and the hours yeah that was like wake up
my poor parents like you know having
their
you know semi-athletic son to get into a
sport that requires them to
drive him to you know a lake in
lake merced at 5 a.m it's not cool
that was always a thing and and we've
talked about this on the podcast before
i was always
blown away by the kids who chose to do
activities where they got up
even earlier in the morning like it was
well to wake up
for high school for me and so the idea
of being like
no you're actually going to get up at
five and you're going to be on a boat
that was not something no no i if i had
to go back in time there's so many
things i would do differently like
people say they
if like did you have any regrets yeah
where you ended yeah i have a ton i have
a
lifetime of them yeah so especially in
high school did so many dumb things
so what
so was the racial makeup of
s i like were there a lot of other
mexican kids there
like what was there were there are
handfuls you know handful
of african-american kids handful of
latino kids enough to have
student unions and clubs you know
there's a black students union asian
students
union and so a lot of san francisco is
predominantly asian
so we had and we were out in the sunset
district which is a
big asian neighborhood um especially now
and even was at the time so we had a lot
of chinese kids at our school
we had a lot of filipino kids because we
were
in uh very close to daly city which is a
huge filipino hub it is what
glendale is to armenians uh daily cities
to filipinos
so we had a ton of filipinos i had to
tell you know it and it was a
decent um mix
and it was uh yeah it was fairly
diverse not when my dad went there he
was like the only
one of the only latino kids uh at the
entire high school
but so did you guys ever like compare
experiences or was it just like
completely different at that point
i i i think at that point i mean
i was too naive to even notice
any i didn't notice any problems i
didn't notice any
diversity issues i really didn't it's
like
i had such a mix of friends i
was friends with everybody that's the
other thing is like i was friends with
all the jocks i would go and use
humor and go around and i made friends
with
every single type of kid so by that
freshman sophomore junior year i
was the guy who knew every single person
at that school
okay so let's that actually brings us to
some of the photos that you have because
we've got some photos of you just kind
of like
with your crew so let's
see this looks like a home thing or a
prom situation it's
a christmas dance i think from
junior year and i brought this sophomore
that's uh monica burns right there with
me i'm sure he should be thrilled
that's monica down low not into me at
all i think liked
another guy i liked her but just
ass girls i think for my junior prom
later that year i drank a lot of tequila
at a party and i asked five girls to my
junior prom and every single one of them
said yes
[Laughter]
so then did you make a bachelor type
rose ceremony to decide
yeah i went around and i i i i did
apologize
two four girls and then ended up taking
one but uh
you guys were pretty much some of my was
like
uh good friends uh and so
guy on the top of the throw eric
burnecker
and then there's jeff elliott and john
claude caligari
the fanta and patrick granny were
part of our sort of like core group of
friends there so since it's an all boys
school
was there like this is such a weird
place was there like a place that y'all
got your girlfriends from was it like we
all
the guys at si always date the girls
from
now it was a solid solid mix
um so there were a bunch of different
girls all one
all girls schools in the city at the
time there was merced
mercy where my uh mom went
and so there's mercy and that was like a
19th avenue i think it's just closing
down now
it was saint rose that closed well
we were you know still you know in high
school i think it closed early 90s or
late late 80s and then there was
confidence the sacred heart
and you sort of got your girlfriends
from one of those
schools um yeah
the question i asked about si did the
girls schools have different
reputations was it like oh the sacred
heart girls they're
the hot ones or whatever
not i mean the the confident of the
sacred heart girls were all it was in
pacific heights in
san francisco which was really suited
fancy
you know if you know san francisco
there's pacific heights is
super i mean they're 12 million dollar
houses
and there was university high school and
then there was
convent of the sacred heart and stewart
hall and town were like those
fancies kids schools
and i grew up in the inner sunset
district my dad was a teamster
and so when we went to these
parties over these you know i went to a
party in a 15 million dollar
house um it was just shocking to me
uh so you so
while you're at the school i imagine
like you're saying you're interacting
with kids who are like
upper tier wealthy did you
loaded did you ever like
did that come into play a lot for you or
did you kind of not really was it kind
of like the racial situation where you
didn't really notice the class dividing
well i
i i always like was friends with pretty
wealthy kids you know we were such a
mixed up group you know it's like san
francisco is divided by golden gate park
so
there's the richmond district and the
sunset district
and those are more like it used to be
san francisco's
now uh because of everything is so
expensive there's so little
real estate that people are just
gobbling up my childhood home that my
parents bought for twenty thousand
dollars in 1970
is probably worth over two million
dollars and it's nothing it's an a-frame
victorian
we all shared a bathroom there were two
bedrooms one bath
and that is probably worth 2.2 million
dollars it's crazy
and it's in the sunset district which
again it's like it's
nice enough but at the time it was
nothing it was a chinese
and irish neighborhood so
again and we'd go over these and we
again we shared a bathroom and i'd go to
a house with somebody who had eight
bathrooms
and me and my friends from the you know
wrong side of the park would just look
at each other like holy it's like
this is crazy i was never comfortable
and i i
i think i really didn't like
rich people at that point i think i've
gotten over
that but i really
hated all of the kids from
the wealthy neighborhoods even though i
was friends with some of them i
sort of and it was probably out of
jealousy too
well i mean it is yeah strange to be in
that situation as a kid and be like
wait you know i imagine you're like i
mean i see my dad working his ass off
all the time and
why do we not have six bathrooms or
whatever
like yeah i didn't even know if i made
too much sense out of it it was just
like
i just deemed them to be
and yeah because for without in that
problem and
a lot of more a lot of them
were you know
out stealing scooters
so um we've also got another picture a
group photo where the girls are all in
white i wanted to pull that one up
yes what is this from
i really couldn't tell you i know who
all those
girls are um but i think
for the most part um i'm rocking that
look at that hair that sure is shaved on
the side
look at me in the back i think that sort
of says everything right there like it
really
everything that we're talking about
that's in pacific heights
that's on a deck i think at the girl in
the pinkish dresses house
and um like this girl at the red belt i
mean she
lived in a house that was just so
expensive i mean we
we zillowed that thing right now which i
could never find
i easily like a 15 million dollar home
that i mean we were just axed like i was
doing beer bongs on her deck
there was one dad that would leave his
house they were never around because the
daughter was like the youngest of
five and the parents were off and
vacationing and jet setting around the
world like
i wore his robe i smoked cigars
and there's the guy had a cigar room in
his house and it's just me and my stupid
friend
smoking his cubans and
so at that at that point we got really
cocky and we're just going through all
their
uh so yeah yeah when
i grew up in sort of the northern
virginia area
and when we would we would like party at
the rich
kids houses and i remember one time
we all took a bath i'm like what is
happening
like why just just to be disrespectful
to their house we're like we're gonna
take a bath
in your bathroom because i
exactly i don't think basketball but
look you see how huge this bath is
yeah like this got jets yeah
but i went to a grammar school with two
of these girls jenna rubia in the front
and then whitney o'hara who's looking
off to the side closest to me
um yeah everybody was i mean
we we had a like innocent group of
friends and that's the other thing he
said
i was the eldest i was so naive and
didn't know anything
i was clueless my parents never had a
sex talk with me
my parents never had any real talk my
dad told me
the same thing every single day was like
pay attention
just pay attention and that was it like
i never got my homework
yeah sorry about this i'm not sure if
you're picking up on this leaf blower
but um yeah yeah it's
it's one of those things i i remind my
kids of it all the time
if anything like my upbringing and
i just don't want people to forget where
they came from in this house and i feel
like i'm the only
person in my family who remembers being
poor like because that's the other thing
to see
we um grew up again didn't have anything
i got my
sports coats from goodwill so my parents
sent me to
fancy schools too so i could
learn how to sort of operate with all
these kids
which was genius on their part and i did
and that's what exactly what happened i
went in all these fancy homes
and saw that that was a thing i was like
i want
this and sort of have been busting my
ass
you know since of my late 20s to try to
achieve that so that's super interesting
you also said
that you know it took you a little while
to like get into
like to find your place at the school
we talked a little bit before recording
um and i would love to pull
up you had a newspaper column correct
yeah so that was all senior year i
really came
alive so that's uh yeah those pictures
there we go
so ask al my buddy ben was the editor of
this
uh newspaper called inside si
and i did a column on the back page all
of senior year called ask out where i
wrote the questions and the answers
and then i had a comment box and then my
you know people would um in a
question box so people would uh drop
questions and i was also the student
body treasurer
okay and um we as i think
john claude and ben we had keys to
offices at that point because all my
friends were presidents of clubs so we
had
like our own office space at the school
i was doing okay at that point i was
pole vaulting
i was playing volleyball i was
in the play i had all extracurricular
activities
zero work being done
i neither of my parents went to uh
college so
um we didn't even know applying for
college was a thing
even though i was going through saint
ignatius college prep
yeah they marched us into
an auditorium and we just filled out
state applications all together
like all of us just filled out our own
state applications
and i got into cal poly
in san luis obispo because i
you know manipulated a bunch of stuff i
was very good at
i did realize all my shortcomings and
worked it so in terms of i became i
think because i was such a bad student
and i you hear this a lot from a lot of
ceos like
um i was such a bad student i became an
excellent communicator because i needed
to compensate for the fact that i needed
to get myself out of trouble so
um i remember going up to a teacher's
senior year and say dr parker
i'm in danger of failing your class and
he said mr madrigal for students like
you
we don't believe in fs i believe in bees
have a wonderful summer
and i was just passed through and i was
actually
our classes salutatorian
uh so there's valedictorian and
salutatorian because i was
the funniest so
because of this column because of an
impression that i did at the principal
because i was i gave funny speeches i
when i ran for treasurer
there were 1300 school kids at the
school and the guy
i remember um mr delay pulled me he was
running the election he goes i want to
show you something
and he pulled me over and he said i've
never seen this ever before
um out of 1300 votes i got 1200 and like
oh my god yes and
uh yeah this is like so again this is a
guy that did not speak
barely like i was i was friendly with
everyone freshman sophomore and junior
year but then senior year sort of again
really was out and participated and took
all those relationships
and the kid that lost to me ended up
transferring
gm osborne yeah he had to leave the
school in shame he's one of my friends i
actually went to
lived with him in college but yeah he
went to sarah
so do you okay first of all
what do you think accounts for that
change of like i'm not involved i'm not
involved suddenly senior year you're
doing all of this stuff you're a
salutatorian which i thought was usually
the person who got the second
highest grade a lot of high schools it
is i think at our high school it became
who
the funniest guy was because there was a
guy named tim reardon
who and now is the principal of of
uh reardon high school um
he he was salutatorian ended up going to
notre dame
but not a good student
that's the other thing is like we've
talked about it do you
yeah he's we could never get into the
colleges that
our kids are getting into now like
there's no way like i i went back to
speak at our high school i'm like one of
their notable alumni after being this
2.0 student
and went back to speak at a business
lunch and i was saying
and there's a lot of people who say they
couldn't get into today's ignatius
i am very certain that i should not have
gotten in back
then like i i had no business
going to this school um just
i can't impress upon you
enough how clueless i was and just
marching
mr magooing my way through so how did i
become this like in
you know like uh stop being such a
wallflower
and i i don't know i remember going up
to a guy or seeing a guy at a concert
that was a year above us that we were
friends with and he goes hey who's
salutatorian
and uh i go yeah it was me and he goes
did you decide to start talking what did
you like what happened what did you do
it's um i couldn't even tell you it's
like
explanation and it's so interesting do
you remember
any of the issues that you covered in
your column
i would um take stuff i mean
i remember my buddy dave gadoy got
busted for smoking pot and
it was he said he was eating a green
apple now and later and
that because they smelled it on him and
it definitely was pot
knowing dave gadoy and he
um and i remember i put a bunch of stuff
in about green apple now and later so i
would always like take it and then
the mr mizeira the guy who busted him
came up to me in the hallway and it's
like very funny
very funny like that like
did you know they all liked it to write
what you
wanted like a little bit you really did
we
they did not censor us at all
um and we i was actually i started a
scholarship at that high school
um for so we do the mario prieto comedy
award
and i do that because this uh priest
actually it's crazy i don't it's just
i'm realizing it's behind me right now
with this picture
but um this is
a photo of mario prieto when i went back
and i
spoke at the school and that's my good
friend john glugowski
again another guy from the wrong side of
the tracks who's one of the most
successful lawyers in san francisco like
he's such a badass
and i do think we both had a similar
experience like he's panamanian and
polish
and i'm half mexican and uh
a sicilian and so like we went to all
these parties together and would be
looking at each other like holy
this is amazing like and now
this guy's in san francisco he like owns
half of russian hill and is this badass
lawyer
like he's uh so i think it's amazing but
this mario prieto comedy award that i
started at the school
it just rewards a person of color
ideally it's not suppo whoever
deserves it gets it but ideally it's a
person of color
that's a junior going into their senior
year
we just pay for some of their tuition
so their parents see that comedy and
being
funny pays oh that's awesome
because i got yelled at yeah when i told
my parents i was gonna be a stand-up
comedian i was scolded
um when i was 28 years old because i
left a family business to do that
so i just want people like a latino
parent to see like you don't have to
force your kid to become a lawyer or a
doctor
if they're funny then
they should go into a career in comedy
talent that is also
a job that your kid can have
um that's so interesting so i'd love to
talk a little bit about
you used to i guess write and perform
some of the pep rallies at your school
so i wanted to pull out
some of the rally photos because that
seems pretty tied to
you becoming a comedian now so
here you are is this just sitting down
those are really some of my
with the exception of the dude on the
bottom right um
uh spacing on his name this guy
that's doing the wonk like an egyptian
thing is imagined selfie
he was hilarious i think he got like as
far as class clown went he got like
number three i was number two
and then those are pretty much all my
friends right there
that's my to like most of my friends
and then i would write and produce i
just did a couple
rallies one was lip syncing battle
wow in 1989 yeah
um and then uh the other one
was a wwf
fight yep and that's me being i played
one of the members of the jesuit
connection
and uh we um there's
me about to get uh thrown against ropes
we set up all the mats and they were
like
really well done and but i was serious
on jason schwartzman from rushmore with
the headset
like saying you guys go go go go with a
clipboard
like in this whole thing wrote the
entire thing had everybody rehearsing
and it was um i think instrumental
in me like you know stepping out of my
shell
and uh getting into comedy later on in
life
for sure and so was this like would you
write i
imagine they were like school specific
sketches similar to like the the column
where you would like
inject school culture into the things
yeah i took two very popular things i
took uh
you know professional wrestling and then
assigned created characters based on all
of our rivals
and then uh and
then uh you know ultimately our school
won
and uh you know yeah so then
did the same thing with a that lip sync
show which was modeled after like there
was a show called putting on the hits
and yeah super old it was it was way
ahead of its time
and i think it was the guy from blue
lagoon who's like christopher atkins or
yeah i was the host of it and so yeah we
can look that up but uh
so it would be like school culture pop
culture
all mixing it together mixed together
and so took a really
popular show and then uh mixed it in
with uh
our rivals yeah and we've got another
photo i believe of you doing an
impression so this you said was an
impression of
the principal the head priest this is
what sort of made me salutatorian so
that
priest that i mentioned that was so
influential in me becoming a stand-up
comic
um uh he
um we yeah i dressed up as sam and
pretended to be him and then this is
will silva
who's actually on air talent for the nfl
network
um so he's on the show called good
morning football on the nfl network
every single
um morning so
and he's their correspondent yeah so the
two of us it was the first time i was
ever did comedy on stage it's right
there in that moment yeah
and again we we we destroyed it was so
fun
so in that as you're doing this like
you're putting together these rallies
you're doing this impression
it's crushing funniest boy in school etc
how much in your brain were you were you
at all thinking like oh i should be a
comedian
or was that not really registering
didn't even know what jobs existed in
comedy i knew that i had two comedians i
grew up with on my block in san
francisco
michael pritchard and mike meehan so the
me and brothers
um it was howard me and chris meehan
uh john there's eight kids in this
family and we were all
pretty close growing up but they were
much older and mike meehan became
a very successful bay area comic
and so he was on the radio and i knew
that i knew that you could become a
comedian
he was on mario joyner's
half hour comedy hour which was on mtv
it was like one of the first stand-up
shows and
i remember watching that and seeing him
on it and just being
thrilled and then so i knew it was a job
it just took me a long time to put it
together again
really clueless if that's the big
um i think take away from all this
is how clueless i was
at the time and going through high
school well that's
why the scholarship that you started is
so interesting because like
you know i was very involved in the
plays and i always was like the funny
person
in the play but i it i feel like that
scholarship it also not even just for
the parents it also tells the kid like
oh also this is a job
like you could do this too because i
just thought i was like well i don't
want to go to theater school
and be an actress so i guess this is
just kind of like the end of it not
realizing like
you could be a comedian and that's a
whole kind of different class
all right so um i think we're coming to
the end here i wanted to pull up your
senior yearbook photo
so that we can take a look here because
i feel like we've done a good job of
kind of
talking about your whole journey from
from wall flower to salutatorian
here we go uh no sideburns
not a good look on anyone always have
sideburns
like yeah fiber and self yeah you look
so young it's crazy like a little baby
um for those who are listening to the
audio version your quote
is i won't stay young forever but i'll
always be immature
do you feel that that have you lived up
to your yearbook
quote i really have i really
i still to this day i mean i'm just uh
look i get made fun of a lot because by
my wife and kids
because i am uh prudish
in a way but in terms of like being
goofy with the kids
like yeah i i definitely
have kept things silly uh
but yeah it's just i don't even know
where i pulled that from
and probably didn't give it much thought
at the time so
it was like everything else in high
school just yeah
here quote done thought of this this
sounds good
um no it definitely took it from
somewhere just
no idea where i grabbed it from um
were you like because you talked a
little bit about drinking tequila your
friend
got caught smoking pot how much like
partying
how much sex rock and roll were you
involved in at this time
sex was just non-existent i got a girl
i had a girlfriend at the end of senior
year
she took me to her prom i took her to my
prom
and that was it i was probably
heartbroken when you know she went to
college
and then um as far as like drinking and
partying
late bloomer there as well i think
my dad so this is interesting actually
um my mom and dad almost
moved to the south bay so my brothers
ended up going to one of those rival
high schools i talked about in the south
bay they didn't go to my same high
school so they went to a co-ed school
called saint francis
where my cousins all went and so they
everyone moved my freshman year
and to a place in cupertino where apple
headquarters are
yeah and they left me sort of and my dad
like we commuted back and forth
a lot but i stayed in san francisco a
lot of nights by myself
and we found the key i remember friends
coming over like senior year
we found the key to our liquor cabinet
because my dad had it hidden
and we had five guys searching the house
and uh we finally found the key to the
liquor cabinet
i always drank a little bit because you
were you grew up pretty fast in
like a densely populated urban
environment like that
and there we were always sort of
drinking from freshman year on
nothing too excessive um
but i think like senior year we really
start building beer bones so we built a
beer bong
called helga which was an uh
sparkles or alhambra bottle that we
spray painted
and you put it on your head and then the
funnel ran
through the handle and then into your
mouth so you couldn't see what people
were pouring in
above you so there was that at parties
and people would flick
cigarettes um there was a tremendous
amount of smoking
uh we all smoked cigarettes like for the
most part
like everyone's smoking clothes and
cigarettes
a lot of um you know uh
we buttoned up shirts all the way to the
top
like it went it was like a preppy slash
mod
thing that we were going for we go to
the fillmore
all the time and go to concerts so i
mean there was the
fishbone and the untouchables i remember
seeing the beastie boys
at license to ill tour madonna used to
own a place on called broadway
called the stone and we
looked at a we didn't get in it was sold
out
and we looked at we were standing
outside
and my buddy ben looked up at the list
and saw kusf which was the university of
san francisco's radio station which was
really hip and cool in the city
saw two names said we were those two
names she crossed them off and let us in
oh that's so cool and um yeah it wasn't
it was insane like the i'm not sure if
you saw any
images or the license tail tour there
was a hooker in a cage
an inflatable penis and i am
15 years old in the front we were with a
13 year old rico brandy
who a girl pushed him in the front row
like we were all up in the front wearing
our little hat you know baseball hat
sideways and just uh having the best
time girl pushes him
he punches the girl across the face and
knocks her out this is a 13 year old boy
punching a girl across the face mca from
the beastie boys
sees it happen pulls the 13 year old up
on stage
sits them in a chair at the concert and
then gives them a
six pack of heineken cans which we
didn't even see him at that point
because there was like kaneki
and bottles only and then uh this 13
year old sat and tried to six pack of
beer will watch in the entire show from
the states
because he was rewarded for punching a
girl across her face
a it different time different time
yeah a simpler time
15 smoking clothes punching ladies
it was it was wild and we we did get
into joe we all went up to legion of
honor which is above
uh so there was two beaches we would do
fires at the beach baker beach
and you know a lot of people would
congregate we'd go out
pretty much every single friday and
saturday night and were you
looking weed at that time or how much oh
no
no no i absolutely like just not like uh
really again naive like i would i would
drink
but scared of smoking pot and where are
you smoking sticks
yes yeah it's so funny to me to be like
i'm not going to smoke weed but i am
going to smoke a clove
which is like put a whole a golf ball
sized hole
in your lungs and just you're coughing
up blood you're like no weed from me
yeah that stuff that's too messed up
all right so i think that we've come to
the end we always
end every episode uh with the same
question
which is if you could tell teenage al
anything what would you tell him
i would tell teenage al
that you have a learning disability
and you need to go and get that
make have the school make accommodations
and i would just be so much of a better
student than i actually was
actually ended up going to university of
san francisco
and just forcing myself to uh and then
like ended up
with a 3.8 in three semesters
um i'm going to tell you one last story
that is this the key
okay i went from cal poly where i
was like shown the door you know i'd get
a 3.1 and then a 1.4 i was not again
did not apply myself because i think i
was scared about
you know applying myself and not being
still not being
good at it so i just chose not to apply
myself
so i um ended up transferring the
university of san francisco
i went from a quarter system to a
semester system and so
none of my stuff transferred i went into
mr skinner who was the
transfer guy and i said mr skinner al
madrigal how are you
my excellent communication skills have
an issue i've taken all these classes
they're not transferring over i took
psychology and now i'm 1.6 credits short
because of the quarter to semester
system and he goes i'm sorry and i was
gonna have to be in college
another three and a half years if that
nothing went through
of school i had already done uh two and
a half years
so it was gonna be oh i'm not gonna
spend like yeah it's gonna be six years
uh and when i should have been in for
four and you're not gonna
be a doctor at the end like comes no
exactly so i was resigned to this
there's nothing i could do i already
committed to being in
school and i remember seeing this guy i
was in a business communications major
there was
all women in my classes except for two
guys one guy named aaron who ended up
being a san francisco cop and another
uh feminine um guy who
most likely gave didn't know but we said
mr skinner will do
anything for me and i overheard that
and i was like okay and i went and
bought white jeans at buffalo exchange
which is like a crossroads and a pink
button-down
polo and i walked in playing this
character
and i said hi mr skinner i have an issue
and i put on this that pretended to be
gay
mr skin you gay baited mr skinner
i totally gay baited mr skinner you
transferred everything over i graduated
in three semesters
you gotta do what you gotta do i don't
give a
i i really i and this is what i'm trying
to tell my kids
like and just one thing is like i i
would go back and tell everybody rules
don't exist
uh even though i i plug like traffic
rules uh
certain things like yes certain basic
life you know
uh civic duties that we have and there
are there are rules but in terms of
like business or uh especially what
we're doing with all things comedy
it's like we are very disruptive um
and so i've always been sort of
disruptive
and so just because i had to be to make
it work
so i don't really abide by too many
established rules or dorms and i'm still
two spanish credits short of
graduating at usf but it's like i got a
diploma
i i got a the diploma case
and i walked down the aisle showed my
parents i threw a hat in the air and i
walked away because like that's what
they wanted
and so i was really doing it for them
and
didn't care about the degree myself like
i still might go back and finish
do you speak spanish no i don't so
that's the other thing is like uh i
i'm learning as much as i can i speak i
can get get
by but it's super crude and i say a lot
of horrible words and i make people
laugh i'm um same way and i majored in
spanish
but at the end i had already decided
that i wanted to be a comedian so
my major was spanish lit and i started
buying the books in english and reading
them in english and then i would write
my paper in spanish and the teacher
would be like
wow elise you really understood the book
oh my god that's another thing i tell my
teenage self to go back and take
spanish all the way through and i'd be a
better
spanish speaker than i am now i should
have that's that's a
huge regret for me is that not you know
my dad had a hard time growing up so we
didn't speak spanish in the house to us
at all
yeah and um yeah i should have gone back
and taken spanish classes that's
i wish i had done that so take spanish
keep disrupting
address your learning disability are
this yes
keep doing what you're doing yeah
you're doing what you're doing bro thank
you
well that's i feel like a perfect end to
the episode
al thank you so much for doing it and
for everybody at home this has been the
roast of your teenage self podcast
you